bonjour c'est Mike vous m'avez parlé
d'un travail et je voulais savoir s'il
était encore disponible oui ah je viens
de sécurité je suis prêt à tout faire
les gamins adoraient cet endroit dans
les années 80 il a fermé il y a des
années mais les proprio ont pas le cœur
de s'en séparer
moi je travaille et toi tu roupies
tout ce que vous avez à faire
c'est surveiller les écrans
bienvenue chez Freddy pas de pizza ou
les rêves les plus fous prennent vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous devez être le nouvel agent de
sécurité
[Musique]
des enfants disparus dans les années 80
la police a fouillé la pizzeria de
Fontenay
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que ça a fermé
les fantômes des gamins possèdent les
robots géants
c'est pas de me prévenir
ça s'appelle des animatroniques
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent
qu'elles deviennent comme
je les arrête
c'est trop tard
reste pas là
[Musique]
vous allez où
pourquoi il faut toujours que j'embarque
des tordu